ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Danah Boyd senior researcher at
Microsoft Research New England good
afternoon thank you so much for coming
out today it put this back here for a
second girl clothing microphones always
a bad combination um I want to talk with
you today about some of my work on
privacy I've been looking at how young
people you think about and understand
privacy for quite some time for those
who aren't familiar with my work I'm an
ethnographer I spend most of my time
running around in the United States
looking at how young people understand
social media as a part of their everyday
life and so my goal today is to talk
about privacy in light of young people
in order to think more generally about
the implications that this has for both
companies and governments now if we
think about young people we've seen a
lot of different kind of social media
disruptions in recent years but what is
it about how do we understand it I think
the most important thing to realize is
that young people use social media as a
part of their everyday life to hang out
with the people that they care about and
they do so in an environment where they
go to the site which is absolutely
common amongst their peers so if they're
in a school where myspace is the
dominant paradigm they're on myspace
these days it's all about Facebook
increasingly we see new iterations of
new technologies Twitter Tumblr
Pinterest popping out and what we see
from young people's participation is
that it's really driven by where all of
their friends are now a lot of people
look at young people's participation in
these social media and say why are they
spending so much time there and indeed
you can look at the kinds of
conversations that may take place and
they seem to basically boil down to yo
what's up how are you good what you
doing nothing and if this kind of
back-and-forth conversation so how do we
actually think about that we can think
of it as a form of social grooming it's
really equivalent to the idea of saying
I like you we're friends yes we are back
and forth and back and forth and these
kind of dynamics are really the gel
makes social media so powerful when we
see young people participating on these
sites they talk about it in terms of
hanging out they talk about it as a
space a space where they can go and be
with their friends joke around laughs
you know and and sort of be a part of
everyday culture with the people that
they know now it's also a way in which
this material becomes documented it
becomes part of a long ongoing kind of
public and this is actually where the
questions of publicness get complicated
so one of the things that I would argue
is that what young people are doing is
that they're participating in a type of
networked public now public's are the
kinds of spaces that you gather whenever
you're hanging out and you want to
actually be a part of something as a
collective you will gather in physical
public spaces places like parks you know
places you know like the mall for some
of you who are growing up or for young
people their participation in publix is
very much about a networked culture a
networked environment and yet the kinds
of publix that they participate in are
very different than the public's that we
understand traditionally and this is
where a lot of the complications arise
especially when we care about issues
like privacy so I want to go through
four key affordances of these kinds of
network public's and talk about three
different dynamics in order to ground
this conversation so that we can go into
a broader conversation about privacy the
first key affordance to keep in mind has
to do with persistence what young people
say online sticks around for a very long
time that means that the embarrassing
things that they wrote when they were
teenagers are still on the internet I
say this is somebody who grew up online
and is amazed that hughesnet is still
around as nice little records of the
embarrassing things that I did it's a
really a synchronicity is a really
powerful tool for actually having
conversations but it's also really
challenging when the kinds of content
that you provide in an online
environment stick around another key
afford is that young people have to
navigate has to do with replicability
again the architecture of the Internet
makes it such that it's very easy to
take bits and share them and and in that
sharing that process involves a lot of
replication well it's very hard also
determined what was the original bit
and what was the duplicate and this
process of replicability is something
that young people have to struggle with
when they see information flowing how do
you know what the original was versus
something that was modified this is
actually one of the challenges for young
people when you're not quite sure who
said what as information spreads and
gossip spreads another key affordance to
keep in mind has to do with
searchability my mother would have loved
the ability to stand in a room and just
sort of scream find like a Harry Potter
movie and figure out where I was off in
the ether she couldn't for which I am
deeply deeply grateful but for a lot of
young people today they're
extraordinarily searchable all right all
it takes to somebody who's curious to
know what they're about a college
admissions officer for example just
search for them yeah it's not just that
young people are searchable they're not
searchable by just anyone they're
searchable by those who have hold power
over them these are parents these are
teachers these are people who want to
market to them these are people who want
to maybe accept them for a job and it
becomes this challenge of searchability
that be that they have to navigate as
they put content up online finally the
fourth key affordance to really keep in
mind has to do with scalability now if
you put something out online and any of
you who have ever done any marketing
know it may be in theory able to reach
Billy a billion plus people but in
reality not that many people visit your
website right and you know a couple
years back when blogging was sort of at
its peak a site called technorati
decided to look at how frequently blogs
were red and found that the average and
I do mean average as in mean the average
blog was read by six people and if you
think about that and you think about
sites like Boing Boing you realize that
the vast majority of blogs are read by
no one and so this becomes a really
interesting trick online is that just
because something can scale to millions
and millions of people doesn't mean it
will and young people quickly learn that
that which scales that which spreads
tends to be that which is most
embarrassing humiliating grotesque or
sexual in fact the things they least
want to spread right and that's where we
have these interesting challenges around
scales how do you deal with an
environment where you're not quite sure
what's going to scale and it's
inevitably the things you least want to
scale now let's think about this in some
of the
dynamics that sort of underpin what's
going on here first there's the issue of
invisible audiences here we are sitting
in microsoft in redmond and i have a
sense of you as an audience you're here
on the public day of tech fest you're
coming because your curiosity you're
curious what's happening at Microsoft
Research and I'm speaking to you in an
environment where I think you at least
have some interest in what I'm saying
but at the other end of that room
there's also a camera pointed at me and
I have no idea who is behind that camera
I have no idea if anything I'm saying
makes sense I don't know if they're
listening to this in 2012 or 2015 I
don't know if they even heard of these
terms I don't know if might what I'm
saying has been chopped up and modified
right that's an invisible audience and
one of the challenges in an online
environment is that young people have to
navigate invisible audiences every day
as a process of participation the
results of which is that by and large
they try to imagine who their audience
is and it's not just young people doing
this this is adults as well you have a
vision of who you think the audience
should be and in fact that's actually
one of the things about the friends list
the friends list on social media is in
many ways an articulation of whom you
want the audience to be who you imagine
it to be and who you think you're
speaking to but how do you navigate all
of these invisible audiences many adults
they like to play ostrich pretend like
those audiences don't exist young people
are hoping that the invisible audiences
might actually pay attention to them in
a positive way but it's always a
challenge another key dynamic that plays
out around this has to do with collapse
contexts again in this room right now we
have an understanding that this is a
lecture and as a lecturer you're
supposed to sit there and pretend like
you're paying attention and nod and
smile and look engaged right that's the
rules we've set up for this room now of
course any one of you could get up and
start dancing on the table right now I
would find it personally very
entertaining but it would completely
violate the idea of what this context is
and that doesn't mean that when you're
you know not out tonight drinking with
your friends you might indeed get up and
start dancing in it be fun part of it is
how do you understand what a given
context is and a context is really
driven by your understanding of the
space the environment of what's going on
what the
rules of and norms are for that space
but also for the people how you relate
to particular people what happens online
is that the context that you're used to
navigating it as discrete contexts
collide in unexpected ways and this is
one of the challenges for you know as we
think about privacy as we think about
these issues of publicity that context
collision is a really hard thing to
navigate third key dynamic that we have
to keep in mind as we think about
privacy has to do with the blurring of
what we'd normally think of as public
and private spaces again we have an
understanding that certain spaces or
more or less public the home is
relatively private although anybody who
has children knows it's not as private
as you want it to be the you know we
have certain ideas of certain spaces
being very public say for example the
park and yet at times we say very
private things in very public places and
vice versa in an online environment
those boundaries get a lot more blurred
and it's that blurring where we start to
see privacy getting contested and
confused so if this is a backdrop I want
to sort of dive into some of the ways in
which young people think about and deal
with privacy first I wanna start with
this great quote which is now a couple
of years old but I still think it's so
poignant it's from a young woman named
Bly and she says my mom always uses the
excuse about the internet being public
when she defends herself and Bly is
referring to her mother's looking at her
online journals of the time and she's
like it's not like I do anything to be
ashamed of but a girl needs her privacy
right and here we have one of the
biggest conflicts about how young people
are struggling to deal with privacy in
an online environment on one hand she
knows that her content is completely
publicly accessible anybody could look
at it but she has this expectation that
her mother is not supposed to be looking
at it that privacy isn't about whether
or not her content is accessible but
what the norms are that govern that
access and that understanding and here's
where we do you have to think through
how young people deal with privacy it's
not about hiding it's not about
excluding oneself from being part of
something instead it's actually about
the ability to have some sense of
control but it's not control over data
which is normally how we talk about
privacy instead is it's a two-part
process one
is the ability to have agency the
ability to actually have some sense of
power within a situation and the second
is to understand the social situation
enough to together be able to actually
exert some control over that situation
and that combination the ability to have
agency and the ability to understand and
interpret the rules of the situation are
extraordinarily hard in an online
environment and they're hard for really
complex reasons first off young people
often have their agency usurped by
adults parents who look over their
shoulders for example they also have you
know their understanding of a social
situation undermined by shifting
nature's of these technologies where all
of a sudden the privacy settings change
where all of a sudden new people are on
the environment and they're trying to
deal with it so they're struggling to
exert some form of control that make
sense of them now that doesn't mean that
they're not trying to participate in
these public spaces and it's actually
their participation in these public
settings where you start to see the sort
of fractures that become important so I
didn't give you an example from a woman
named Alicia who Alice marwick and I
actually went down and interviewed I
think that she highlights something very
important here because she talks about
some of the shifts and her struggles
with it she says I just think that
technology is redefining what's
acceptable for people to put out about
themselves I've grown up with technology
so I don't know how it was before this
boom of social networking but it seems
like instead of spending all of our time
talking to other individual people and
sharing things that would seem private
we spend our time putting it up in one
module of communication where people can
go and access it if they want to right
now what she's highlighting is a shift
that has happened a shift because of the
technical affordances and she doesn't
even realize the importance of that
shift but I want to sort of play it out
for you if we were having a conversation
say in the hallway our interaction would
be in many ways private by default
public with effort it would be private
by default just because the conversation
could only be overheard so far it would
be public by effort because if you
wanted to share what we talked about you
would have to go out of your way to
publicize it it would take these steps
to publicize it and so we make a
decision
then about what to publicize yet in an
online environment these things swap
this goes to the absolute opposite
direction that participation in social
media is in many ways public by default
private through effort our interactions
online it's easier to put them up and
make them broadly accessible and then
choose what to exclude and indeed that's
what we see young people doing on a
regular basis that they actually choose
what to exclude from public discourse as
opposed to what to include and that
shift is really really confusing to
people because if you're not prepared
for it you sit there and say why are you
sharing your breakfast I don't want to
know about your breakfast when the
inverse attitude is there's nothing
wrong with sharing my breakfast I might
as well share it and if you don't like
it you'll move on right and that's a
really radical shift in terms of
navigating these issues part of it has
to do with the fact that young people
are not trying to be public they're not
trying to be seen by everybody across
all space and all time but rather
they're trying to find a public that
they can participate in and this is
really important in light especially of
an American context where young people
have few opportunities to engage with
their peers in an unstructured setting a
place where they can just hang out and
those spaces those public's become
extraordinarily important to them so
they look to social media as an attempt
to find a public that they can
participate in but it doesn't mean that
they're trying to be public and that's
an important distinction now as i'm
participating in those public's though
they don't understand why other people
don't understand the rules of those
public's why adults don't see that this
is not a space for them and inevitably
there are constant complaints about
teachers or parents what are they doing
looking at this material they don't
belong there and this is where we start
to see young people trying to develop
strategies so I want to highlight are
the kinds of stuff you know a few
examples of strategies that young people
take to achieve privacy many of these
have parallels in an offline setting but
I'm going to talk about them in an
online setting because I think that
they're important I'm going to begin
with a young person by the name of
hunter and Hunter is a young man living
in DC and he's dealing with very
wrong context collapses in his world he
is going to a private not a private
public charter school that's really for
really intelligent highly academic young
people um he's really excited about his
school he likes being a part of this
geeky environment but he also comes from
a working-class environment that is very
different he likes to talk about it and
particularly talk about his sister as
quote unquote ghetto um and so one of
the things she's dealing with on
Facebook is it he has to deal with these
conflicting worlds about how he has
simultaneously interactions with his his
friends and his peers and with his
sister and so what he says here is when
I'm talking to my friends on Facebook or
I put up a status something I hate is
when people who I'm not addressing my
statuses comment on them in my old
school people used to always call me
nerdy and then I was the least black
black person they've ever met some would
say that on facebook and I you know I'd
say should I take offense to the fact
that someone put the ringtone white and
nerdy is for me and it was a joke I
guess we were all talking about it and
my sister comes out of nowhere she's
like oh baby bro and I'm like no don't
say that I wasn't talking to you alright
so asking hunter about this is like how
are you supposed to navigate this and
he's like well it's just I think there
are certain ways you talk you know she
was pointing out he would talk to his
sister differently than he would talk to
his friends and he really thought his
sister should know this and he
constantly struggled because no amount
of asserting of the social norms meant
that his sister got it so instead he
started actually developing technical
means to keep people out hunter and his
friends at school were really interested
in old classic video games and other
other material which by the way again it
pains me where his notion of classic
video games was the legends of Zelda
which makes me feel sufficiently old but
he was talking about how he loved to
geek out on legends of Zelda and about
pokemon but if you would write about
these things on Facebook his cousins and
his sister would make fun of him because
what was cool within that group was much
more in the world of shooter video games
and so he got to a point where he
decided that any time you would talk
about pokemon or legends of Zelda he
would go out of his way to block people
and he would make a special list just to
talk about these things not because he
was trying to hide these
his interest in Zelda but he didn't want
to deal with the contacts collisions he
didn't want to deal with the awkward
dynamics between different people this
is one of the strategies for achieving
privacy it's a very technical strategy
but it's also one of the things that's
really hard to do and so young people
are dealing with that and the next two
strategies i'm going to give you our
very technical strategy and they're very
unique to the two young women that i'm
going to talk about but they're
important to highlight the kinds of
extremes that young people will go to
the first has to do with a young woman
by the name of shamika that we met in DC
and shemika was constantly dealing with
drama in her school and she was
frustrated because people would go back
way into facebook and take things from
you know long time ago as in like a
month or two months ago and they would
bring it back to the forefront and they
would turn it into a big deal so she got
to a point where when she would log into
Facebook she would read a comment that
was left to her and then she would
delete it and she would go and she would
leave comments on other people's sites
are other peoples pages she would mark
things up and then the next day she
would go and she would delete the
messages she left and she talked about
it in terms of basically keeping
Facebook perfectly clean perfectly empty
there was no long-term or persistent
record of Facebook right and it didn't
mean that she didn't think that it could
be recorded in fact one of the things
were asked her is that you know well
Facebook has a copy of this where your
friends can copy of it she's like yeah
but if you go to that much effort you're
really creepy right it was a recognition
that this was a way of signaling to her
peers that pulling this stuff from the
past was not appropriate macaela which
is also from DC it was dealing with a
different set of dynamics she was is
dealing with the fact that she's under
state supervision she's in foster care
she's dealing with different dynamics in
terms of adults looking in on her life
on a regular basis and she knew that
they were looking for online records of
what she was doing so when Facebook put
together a feature to it was sorry when
Facebook decided that it didn't want
people to delete their accounts what it
gave them was an option where if you go
to try to delete your account it was it
really you don't want to do that just to
activate it and if you feel like coming
back everything will be there for you
well Michaela took that to an extreme so
what would happen is
that every day at the end of her use of
Facebook she would deactivate her
account that would render her entirely
invisible in the system it would mean
nobody could message her it mean that
nobody could see her profile and then
the next day when she would log back in
she would reactivate her account and our
account was basically invisible X all
points except during the moments in
which she was logged in right she made
it a real-time activity pretty powerful
way of going about this and when I was
asking her about you know why how does
this play out just like well you know
nobody no adult looks at this at night
right which is again the sort of way of
trying to understand the circumstances
and exactly some sort of control over it
now these are extreme approaches but I
want to talk about a sort of more common
approach carmen was a young woman that
we met in massachusetts and carmen
really loved her mother they were super
super close she was super excited to
have her mother on facebook with her
there was all sorts of good dialogues
but she couldn't stand when her mother
would sort of over react to things and
her mother had this tendency to want to
comment on everything and as carmen
points out is that is a little
overwhelming because everybody
disappears after the mom post alright so
when mom comments no one responds well
the other thing about Carmen's mom is
that Karma's mom tends to overreact to
what Carmen says especially emotional
things and so Carmen is always trying to
find a way to convey emotions to her
friends without them overreacting or
without her mom overreacting one day
carmen and her boyfriend break up and
she's having a pretty crappy day and she
wants to explain this to her friends she
or she wants to sort of gather some sort
of support and so she thinks about you
know expressing herself and as a
teenager expressing herself and her
emotions means putting up song lyrics
but she knew if you put up any sort of
sappy song lyric that her mother would
go you know crazy would think she was
suicidal so she decided to do something
um which she knew would not be visible
to her parent her mother but would be to
her friends she decided to put up song
lyrics from always look on the bright
side of life now for those who don't get
the monty python reference this is a
very chipper and happy song always look
on the bright side of life some during a
part of the movie where the key
character is about to be executed it is
not a happy scene and she knew that her
friends had just recently seen
this movie she knew that it was outside
of the cultural purview of her mother
and so she puts up these song lyrics her
mother immediately comments oh it looks
like you're having a great day and her
friends immediately call her right and
this is a really powerful tactic for
achieving privacy in a public
environment it's something that in many
ways we've understood especially in the
computer science world as steganography
it's a cryptographic notion of hiding in
plain sight and what Carmen is doing is
a form of social steganography she is
making it possible to convey a really
detailed message while hiding in plain
sight now I've been talking to young
people for the better part of a decade
and one of the things that I find really
startling over the decades that I've
been looking at social media is how I
increasingly cannot tell what they're
talking about on social media and it's
not because I don't understand the
cultural references I can I i watch way
too much teen TV I know way too much
about teen music but it's the fact that
I am actually not located within their
peer group I don't know they're in jokes
and most of what they're starting to do
in social media is put up a whole set of
encoded information there they're
conveying a lot of detailed private
information because but I can't make
sense of it and what we see is that
young people have found that the most
reasonable tactic for achieving privacy
in a networked public environment is to
make the content itself perfectly
accessible but make certain that the
meaning is not at all accessible and
that is extremely powerful it's not just
young people that are doing this we're
starting to see this as a dolt sand a
whole group of people it's also not
entirely new and one of the things that
I find interesting talking to activists
in particular is how this was a tactic
of oppressed populations forever right
and so again what do we think about
teenagers as at a press population
something to sort of leaving ponder with
so I want to sort of roll this forward
and what does this mean as we start to
go forward many of you in the room are
interested in all sorts of different
notions of privacy issues of data
privacy issues of you know how to deal
with the complex big data problems that
we're starting to see and most of what
I've just been talking about is what i
would call social privacy i think it's
important to recognize that
are all of these conflicting issues with
privacy that are coming up and emerging
young people in many ways are paying no
attention to what companies or what
governments are doing they don't know
how to make sense of it it's not within
a cultural frame of course there's a lot
of great you know scholarly data that
shows that adults also have no clue
what's happening with companies or
governments either so it's not that
young people are especially clueless
it's pretty much that everyone has no
clue what's going on